Sen har vi inte helt ärligt satsat jättemycket på försäljning av plattformar.
Jag tror att kommande åren kan län fosas upp mycket mer.
Jag hoppas att den har mycket mer potential.
Make Sweden Stronger.
Nu gick vi in, du ska få berätta lite om dig själv, men jag hoppar in här lite.
Det är rätt sjukt att ni har omsätt en 160 miljoner.
Jag är ju chanobilgenerationen, jag kan inte ta...
Du vet, vem är du typ?
Det låter inte så jävla verkligt.
Du har ren dess bra ord.
Ni har inga sura kolleger, ni bråkar aldrig och det finns inga tulliga ögonblick.
Nu kanske jag får skit för detta, men jag säger det.
Jag håller med.
Men, vad brinner ni mest för?
Idag välkomnar vi Ali Gåset från Gordon Delivery till podden Make Sweden Stronger.
Du driver ju ett sånt där bolag som jag tänker att de flesta av oss kanske blir lite rädda för.
Vi skulle inte vilja, ofta när man sitter och tänker vad ska man starta så tänker man ju någonting med låga overhead-avgifter och en enkel struktur.
Men att dra igång ett, kallar man det faktbolag eller logistikbolag med lastbilar som ska köra kylvaror med bokningssystem, det är ju liksom inte första idén man sätter igång.
Eller är det?
Var det din?
Nej men det är nog ganska klokt.
Så jag tror att det var väl mycket av okunskap som det blev det här.
Jag hade ju liksom aldrig jobbat med transport eller logistik tidigare.
Är det inte ännu mer märkligt då att bara, fuck it, vi kör.
Jo, så jag visste egentligen inte riktigt vad jag gav mig in på heller.
Men det som triggade mig, det som attraherade ändå var att e-handeln hade redan då vuxit länge.
Vi startade bolaget 2015, så det är tio år sedan.
Men leveransupplevelsen för konsumenten var jättedålig.
Det är lätt att glömma bort det.
Det är sjukt mycket bättre idag.
Det var dagtidsleveranser, du fick inte reda på när det kommer.
Du fick en latt i brevlådan, att den ska komma på torsdag.
Så du fick vara hemma hela dagen.
Det här är innan covid så ingen jobbade hemifrån då heller.
Så kom den ändå inte.
Man kunde inte få ta på fören eller bo fraktbolaget.
Det var väldigt mycket som var väldigt dåligt.
Det var utifrån att försöka göra det bättre som idén kom.
Från allra början så var inte tanken att vi skulle äga lastbilar för det.
Vi tänkte mer att vi ska, min bakgrund från mjukvarubranchen, tanken var att bygga en plattform för att koppla utförare av den här tjänsten med handlare som behöver få sina varor levererade.
Så att det skulle vara 19-20-åringar som har tagit körkort som kan köra med föräldrarnas bil på kvällarna och extra checka.
Och det var faktiskt så när det började det hela.
Jag har hört lite om din story här, nu hoppar vi liksom bara rakt in i det.
Men vi kan väl säga att jag tror att de flesta som lyssnar på detta vet vad Gordon Delivery är.
Men ni kör ut grejer, men ni gör väl kylda leveranser, är inte det en av de stora unika punkterna?
Precis, precis.
Vi kallade det för kyld tidigare, men idag så kallar vi det för temperaturkontrollerad.
Ja, vackert.
Ja, och det kan vara olika temperaturintervaller.
Ibland kunde det vara att man måste hålla det varmt också under viss tid, beroende på vad man levererade.
Så precis som vi har nischat oss, och 2015, då var e-handel, det fanns ju stora e-handlare, men e-handeln med mat var väldigt, väldigt litet.
Och då kollade vi lite, vad hände i USA och såg lite andra bolag som började poppa upp inom online grocery.
Ja, och det var liksom, tänkte att det här kan vara nästa stora grej.
Och jag visste att Ica skulle det året satsa på e-handel, eller gå live med deras e-handel.
Då var det svårare att börja det, tänkte vi, men det här är en nisch som vi kan ta.
Men gjordes de två idéerna samtidigt?
För du nämnde att ni egentligen, kanske från början tänkte en plattform, och jag vet att ni har den plattformen fortfarande och säljer den plattformen, men gjorde ni de här första leveranserna för att testa ett eget system?
Eller var det mer så att vi gör två affärsidéer på samma gång?
Du menar tech-plattformen och leveransen eller?
Ja, precis.
Det var faktiskt så illa så att i början startade vi utan riskkapital.
Som man gör när man ska bygga en tech-plattform och ett logistikbolag.
Ja, precis.
Det är ganska dåliga förutsättningar.
Så i början hade vi inte råd att utveckla någon plattform, så vi började faktiskt med en vision om plattformen och började utföra tjänsten.
Våra första kunder var IK-handlare och de skulle gå live med sin e-handel.
Då sa vi att outsorza plocket och leveransen till oss.
Ni är ju bäst i Sverige på att drifta butik.
Låt oss ta en drifta e-handel.
Vi hade egentligen ingen plattform, så det var väldigt manuellt allting.
Så vi testade både att plocka och leverera och då var det precis så.
Det var liksom unga som körde med kombibilar med frigoliklådor.
Det låter sjukt idag, men det funkar det då.
Satte ni upp en Ica-banner på sidan då eller?
Ja, vi körde inga Ica-banners.
Vi hade faktiskt magnetlappar med Gordon på.
Så att Gordon får bilarna.
Så det var så det började och plattformen började vi utveckla egentligen.
Man kan säga så här, i början så var jag ganska ensam i själva bolaget.
Då var det väldigt lärorikt, istället för att börja utveckla saker och ting, så testade jag en jäkla massa programvaror själv i det här området.
Jag testade massor av ruttopprimeringssystem, förareappar, så jag körde väldigt mycket med 3D partsgrejer i början.
Det som var väldigt bra, dels så lärde jag mig vad som fungerade bra och dåligt, och sen när man väl ska bygga någonting själv, då är risken mer lätt att det blir rätt än fel.
Det är alltid farligt att utveckla när man inte har erfarenhet av verksamheten.
Så det är väldigt skönt att ha erfarenhet av verksamheten och sen börja utveckla.
Då är du mycket duktigare kravställare än att utveckla på spekulation, som många IT-bolag gör.
Skulle du säga att du är Sveriges mest sociala programvaruutvecklare?
Hahaha, som personbildare eller?
Ja, haha, det är en bra fråga.
Det får jag andra avgöra.
Hahaha, man har ju träffat några genom åren, de föredrar ju helst att gömma sig.
Men det får man göra.
Ja, precis.
Nej, jag ska inte fasta i det, skitsamma.
Okej, i början köpte ni lite kombobilar, och så började du fundera på att de här systemen var ju skit.
När blev det liksom, nu tar vi in lastbilar.
Nu har vi inte bara en lapp, utan nu trycker vi upp lastbilen med Gordon.
Ja, ja.
Nej men det var faktiskt 2017, och då var, du vet i första åren är det ju lite trial and error, man lär sig väldigt mycket, man tar nya kunder, förstår hur det funkar, lär sig deras problem, nyckeltalen, vad som är viktigt, flaskalta och så vidare.
Så vi körde ganska brett 2015-2016.
Vi började med mat, det var liksom det vi började med, men vi testade också att leverera annat också, typ blommor, och vi leverade julgranar tre år i dag, och allt möjligt.
Men 2017 beskrivde vi att vi nischade oss och ska bli bra på en sak.
Då bestämde vi oss ut med det temperaturkontrollerat som vi ska satsa på.
Det var också det året vi steppade upp och investerade i kylbilar och kom igång på riktigt.
Men då måste ni ha fått en investering, eller hur löste ni den ekonomin?
Första investeringen var ungefär ett år efter starten.
Då tog vi in ganska lite pengar, det tog in 970 000.
Det räcker inte jättelångt i den här typen av investering.
Är det två hjul på en lastbil?
Ja, det är väldigt lite och det är en lågmarginal bransch.
Det kräver volym för att vi ska kunna nå lön som helst.
Vi fick faktiskt en otroligt sjukt deal av en kund.
Det var ovärderligt.
Det var så här att de hade ett kontrakt med ett bolag som skötte deras leveranser.
De hade kylbilar, sex stycken.
De var missnöjda med det här bolaget.
Idels avtal, de hade ett långt avtal, tre-
eller femårsavtal.
Så stod det att ifall de säger upp avtalet så har de rätt att ta över leasing-avtalen från leverantören.
Då var det här kunden så pass schysst, så sa de att vi kan inte få lånabanken för att lease så här mycket bilar.
Då sa han att då tar vi oss den så skriver vi ett nyttjande rättsavtal så att ni betalar allt i bilarna så att de blir lite vår bank, kunden.
Så kunden tog egentligen den risken och vi fick tillgång till bilarna, så det var starten.
Det var jätte, jätte bra och sen så tog vi in lite mer pengar, men vi tog in ganska små belopp fram till 2021 faktiskt.
Det känns som då gick många bolag i någon sorts antingen på anabolasteroider eller så kraschar man.
Det känns som att det fanns någon sorts skiljeläge där och ni fick ett tryck då, det flög iväg.
Eller vad var det som var den stora grejen då?
Var det att folk behövde mat hem liksom?
Ja, precis.
Det var exakt det.
Dels så 2019 när covid slog till, vi var väl ganska förberedda.
Vi hade redan, jag tror 2018 började vi vår geografiska expansion.
Då startade vi i Malmö, Göteborg.
Vi började få upp ett samordnat flöde.
Vi hade etablerat processerna, systemet.
Var ni på er plattform nu eller hade ni?
Ja, nu är vi på vår plattform.
Det är 2018, absolut.
När pandemin slog till var vi liksom, vi hade precis kommit upp till den nivån där vi kunde skala upp.
Så timingmässigt var det ju otroligt.
Som du säger var det ju liksom, antingen gick det skitdåligt för bolag, så det var ju väldigt tuffa tider och för andra gick det jättebra.
Ja, du vet ju hur det var liksom.
Det som ökade mest innan e-handel under de åren var mat.
För att det var restriktioner att folk skulle gå och handla och så vidare.
Så mat var det som ökade väldigt väldigt mycket.
Så vi gick från 38 miljoner till 111 miljoner i omsättning till 418 eller något sånt där.
Så på två år så, vi gick från 38 till 400 miljoner i omsättning.
Vad innebär det i personal?
Jag fattar siffror på något sätt, men det måste ju vara en jävla massa nya människor som ska in i systemet.
Nej men det är verkligen det.
Det är vår bussiness handlar ju också om.
Omsättningen är ju jättemånga leveranser.
Och varenda leverans kräver att all kedja funkar hela vägen bakom.
Att man kommer till rätt terminal, fast på det är det nästa terminal.
Varenda är det tid för att lasta ut och så vidare.
Man kan säga att det som var väldigt tufft egentligen 2017-2018 när vi började, det var hantering av människor och moment.
Du frågade i början hur du kunde visa att du körde här eller något helt galet och startade ett sånt här bolag.
Jag hade lätt utvecklingsteam och produktteam och jobbat med utvecklare, akademiker och helt plötsligt.
Jag försökte rekrytera förare på samma sätt eftersom det var det enda jag kunde.
Jag blev otroligt otydlig.
De ville ju veta när jag ska börja, vad ska jag göra, vad händer om det här inträffar och så vidare.
Det var väldigt mycket människor och moment.
Och det var en smärtsam resa.
Det var bilar som gick sönder, folk som inte dockade upp, personer som...
Tjugo åringar som bor hemma och gamar hela natten och så är de trötta på morgonen så dyker de inte upp.
Och vi ställde ju aldrig in en enda rutt.
Så det blir skitjobbigt.
Så jag tugg in två psykologi studenter som gjorde sitt x-jobb här för att analysera vilka egenskap vi ska söka i de här personerna för att vi ska slippa det här problemet att de dyker inte upp eller slutar efter tre dagar.
Och det var väldigt lärorikt.
Vi lärde oss sjukt mycket tillsammans med dem.
Vad kom ni fram till?
De gjorde ett jäkla bra jobb.
De åkte ut med föräldrar så att de förstod deras vardag.
De intervjuade många.
De hittade en amerikansk databas där man har gjort en kartläggning av alla personliga egenskaper kopplat till arbetsuppgifter för att få en hömme om vilka personliga egenskaper är viktigt i föraryrket.
Det de kom fram till var något som överraskade mig.
Det absolut viktigaste att vi skulle söka efter i en intervju var samvetsglönhet.
Det låter konstigt men vi får tänka det här.
Det är typen av jobb.
Det är ingen chef som ser personen.
De åker runt med en bil som kostar 600-700.000.
De kan backa på någon och bara ingen såg köra vidare.
Det blev en matlade överrätta hem det.
Det ligger snusdosa i kastet.
Jag tar den.
Jag har tankkort, jag ringer en polare och kommer över och tankar din bil så betalar jag.
Alla de här grejerna har ju inträffat med oss.
Vi hade en tjej som hade nallat bensin för 20.000 i Falun.
Det är ganska många tankningar alltså.
Det är ganska många och så är det väldigt självständigt jobb liksom.
Man ska kunna och det är ganska hög kognitiv behov liksom.
Det är många situationer som uppkommer i det här yrket.
Allafall, det är de jättetill med det som var, man kan ju veta allt det här men vad ska man göra med det.
De gjorde en sjukt bra intervjumodell där vi intervjuade på sju minuter tror jag, med ett antal frågor för att validera om det här är rätt eller inte.
Så vi lärde oss väldigt mycket under den fasen.
Så vi var ganska väl förberedda för att skala upp.
Sedan när pandemin kom och det började dra iväg, då var det en väldigt mycket rock'n'roll, att starta i nya städer, nya orter.
Vi gick säkert från 30-40% av Sveriges befolkning till 90% på väldigt kort tid.
Så det är väldigt mycket att göra.
Men jag tror att det absolut, absolut viktigaste under den perioden, det var liksom sammanhållningen, kulturen, att alla jobbade för bolagets bästa, ville det här.
Det var också väldigt kul under den tiden.
När du säger så, så säger man ju ofta, men som sagt, de sitter ju ofta i en bil liksom, och så kör man iväg och så är man på egen.
Hur håller man en sammanhållning i den processen?
Så sitter alla på en enda stor Discord-chatt och bara snackar med varandra om...
Precis.
En ganska svår grupp att hålla samman liksom.
Det är det, det är det.
Vi har ju liksom, du vet när jag hade precis startat bolaget, då lyckades vi få enligt artiklar i tidningarna, och då ringde ett transportbolag, ägaren till ett transportbolag mig och sa såhär, ja men jag vill träffa dig så åkte jag dit.
Och träffade honom, jag hade aldrig varit på ett sånt ställe innan, och då sa han såhär, här är vår kontrollton.
Så jag hade aldrig hört det ordet förut såhär, jag bara aha, kontrollton, det lät ju som flygton, eller någon såhär, som en yberg, människor som övervakar förarna.
Och då tänkte jag såhär, fan vi ska inte kalla, vi är till för att supporta våra förare så att de ska lyckas.
Jag ritade allt i organisationsbilden upp och ner, vänd liksom, att jag var längst ner, och det är de som träffar kunderna och skapar värde, det är de som är liksom, first line.
Så vi kallade vår kontrollton för success tower, alltså vår uppgift att de ska lyckas varje dag.
Jag tror att vi, liksom de som jobbar på vår så kallad trafikledning och workforce, de har så otrolig bra relationer med förarna.
De vet liksom vad deras barn heter, de vet väldigt mycket om.
Så jag tror att det handlar om relationer tror jag.
Fan det låter så trevligt när du säger det.
Om jag går till mina anställda och säger jag vet vad dina barn heter, så låter det mycket mer aggressivt.
Alltså det är nu på att vara, ja.
Nej, absolut.
En helt random fråga som inte har med någonting att göra.
Hur många tror att du heter Gordon?
Ja det är ganska vanligt, speciellt i början, så sa folk Gordon till mig och trodde att jag hette Gordon.
Varför Gordon då?
Ja, vi ville att det skulle vara ett personnamn.
Alla logistiska bolag hette akronymer, DHL, UPS, DPD och så vidare.
Så det skulle vara personnamn och personligt liksom.
Och det följde på Gordon.
Anledningen till att det var just Gordon, det var att min sons favorit tv-program var Tåget Thomas, om du vet vilken det är.
Det är ett gammalt brittiskt tecknande film.
Så det är en massa tåg som har olika personligheter.
Och ett av dem på tågen hette Gordon, som var hans favorit tåg.
Så det kommer från Tåget Thomas.
Okej, hoppas att du har fått det här.
Ni hade ju den här rätt bizarra tillväxten, får man ändå säga att det var.
Och sen har det varit lite stagnerat.
Det har legat, när vi säger stagnerat, jag hade med Johan från Gymmgrossisterna här i podden, och de omsätter ju typ, vad sa han nu, en och en halv miljard eller något sånt där.
Och när man säger så här, ja ni har stagnerat, så är det så här, absolut, vi måste fortfarande sälja för en och en halv miljard.
Det är liksom, och det är samma sak här, när man säger att jag har stagnerat, absolut det är fortfarande en halv miljard ni ska skicka paket för.
Så det är rätt mycket transporter.
Verkligen.
Men det har varit intressant att få höra lite hur ni anpassar, för jag antar att det är gjort av att helt plötsligt så öppnade samhället upp igen och så ska man anpassa sig från att vara en rekryterande tillväxtbusiness till att bli en mer, okej, har vi koll på allting?
Vad fan var det vi fuckade upp under den här tiden?
Och det här har vi missat.
Och sen så vi pratade lite här kort innan, att nu verkar det ha tagit fart lite igen.
Det har varit ett bra år här.
Det hade varit kul att prata om också vad som har gjort ökningen här i nästa steg.
Om du orkar ta oss lite på den resan där.
Ja men jag tycker faktiskt det kanske är det som är en närm som känns roligast.
Men jag tycker att den nyttigaste perioden i bodragshistoria är just 2023-2024, de här tuffa åren.
Det som hände efter pandemin, det var att e-handeln och mat gick ner ganska plastiskt.
Då går ju våra volymer ner, så det är inte mer med det.
Ja, och det var liksom första gången någonsin.
Vi har haft ett år i bodragshistoria, vi inte har växt, och det är 2023.
Och vi backade i och för sig bara ett par procent, så det var inte jättemycket.
Men för nu säger du att omsättningen gick ner, men som du säger, den gick inte ner så mycket och handeln med mat måste ju ha stagnerat stenhårt.
Så hur lyckades ni ändå bibehålla omsättningen där uppe?
Men varför har den inte tappat mer?
Precis.
Vi har jobbat jättemycket med att ta in nya kunder.
Vi öppnade också i Danmark och Norge under 2021.
Vi har jobbat med att ta in fler kunder för att kompensera tappet från de andra kunderna eller marknaden.
Men det är så att det var väldigt tydligt från att ha vuxit.
När du har jättepokus på att fixa i den här typen av verksamhet som är väldigt operationellt intensiv, då är det väldigt mycket, jag brukar säga rock'n'roll, det är väldigt mycket fixa och lösa problem.
Nu ska vi öppna en ny terminal i Karlstad, nu ska vi till Norrland, nu ska vi göra det i Oslo, Köpenhamn och så vidare.
Det är mycket fixa och lösa problem i den tiden.
När vi skulle ställa om när tillväxten inte går på det sättet, då behöver man jobba mycket med processerna, kvaliteten, hur gör vi det effektivare, lönsamhet blir otroligt viktigt.
Samtidigt som volymerna minskade efter pandemin, så ökade också kvalitetskraven för våra kunder, prispressen ökade, så det blev också mycket tuffare klimat på många sätt.
Så man kan säga att i de två åren ställde vi om bolaget ganska mycket, och också organisatoriskt.
Vissa personer passar väldigt mycket bra under tillväxt, alltså lösa problem och så vidare.
Men om samma person ska jobba med analys och jobba med annorlunda processer och kvalitet, det är inte alltid samma person.
Så det var också en stor organisatorisk omställning som vi behövde förnya lite också i bolaget, få en struktur och vi tillsatte vissa roller som vi inte hade haft, för att verkligen tänka långsiktigt, riktigt långsiktigt, och bygga en robusthet i bolaget för att kunna ha en mer mogen tillväxt med lönsamhet.
Ägarna och styrelsen och jag bestämde att vi satte ganska tuff mål att nå en miljard under kommande åren och med lönsamhet också.
Och pratade med folk som jobbar på gårdar och personal.
Alla är supermedvetna om målen och så har vi jobbat verkligen med kvalitet, ordning och processer.
Men också sjukt mycket med vår tillväxtplan.
Vi har också breddat vår marknad.
Vi har gått in väldigt mycket i läkemedel som också kräver temperaturkontrollerat.
Men också med ännu mer rigorösa krav och regelverk och så vidare.
Nu taktar vi 20-30 procents tillväxt här under hela året.
Varje månad och är lönsamma på rullande tolv och avkänner bättre än förkast.
Är du rock'n'roll-personen eller processtypen?
Vilken skala tilltalar dig mest?
Ganska mycket av båda, ganska tråkigt svar.
Men jag tror att överhuvudtaget för nu omsätter vi på rullande tål nära 640 miljoner och på tio år har gått från 0 till 640 miljoner från att ha varit ensam till en-två personer till att ha mycket större organisation.
Det kräver ju helt annan typ av ledarskap varje år egentligen.
Det gäller ju att ställa om eller vara öppen för att bolaget behöver andra saker.
Men jag tycker att det är kul, jag tycker att det var fantastiskt roligt med rock'n'roll perioden.
Det är lätt att, du vet när det är rock'n'roll, det brukar jag säga.
Det är lättbelöning när du löser problem.
Det ramlar grejer hela tiden från himlen.
Du ska bara lösa, lösa, lösa.
Du känner ju dig jävligt duktig när du hela tiden löser.
Men det är väldigt svårt att vara proaktiv och långsiktig när du hela tiden är i det här lösa problem-mål hela tiden.
Här och nu.
Men nu när ni har så stark tillväxt, känns det rock'n'roll nu eller känns det som en dämpad rock'n'roll för att ni har satt en ny grund, en bas som ni jobbar ifrån.
Känns det mer som, ja nej men det här ska vi göra.
Ja nej men det är mycket mer dämpad rock'n'roll, det är mycket mer strukturerad rock'n'roll, eller såhär, orchestrerad rock'n'roll.
Och nu kan vi så mycket, nu har vi också så mycket duktiga människor och jobbar sjukt mycket med data och kan simulera saker i förväg och förstå vilka risker vi tar på ett annat sätt än vad vi visste i tidig fas.
Så det är mycket mer kontrollerad rock'n'roll.
Jag fattar.
Det behöver du inte svara på om du inte vill såklart, men är du största aktieägare fortfarande i bolaget?
Jag är, jag och vår största ägare har ungefär lika mycket.
Jag fattar, men så folk inom bolaget, är det fortfarande dig som är liksom the real pappa.
Om du säger något så lyssnar de.
Ja precis, så är det nog.
Sen så har jag själv varit ganska omedveten om det faktiskt.
Jag är liksom som alla andra, det är ingen skillnad på mig än någon annan här på bolaget.
Tror du inte folk blir sura på det?
När du är såhär, kom du och jag är vi samma.
Och så är de såhär, sluta, ha käften nu.
Du säger vad jag ska göra.
Nej men det är verkligen så.
Och det här var en insikt som tog ganska lång tid när jag fattade det.
För det var någon som, för i början när vi inte var så många, då sa jag såhär, varför säger ingen inboots?
Jag är van att folk ska säga vad de tycker och komma med andra idéer.
Och då var det någon som sa att du måste fatta att du är grundare och ägare och såhär.
Du måste ju fatta det.
Och det tog ett tag innan jag fattade det faktiskt.
Ja, blev det jobbigt att fatta det och så blev det helt plötsligt så att folk sa emot det och så tänkte du fan, det var mycket skönt när folk inte sa emot det.
Nej, jag trivs ju bra när folk är liksom, jag tror också att det handlar om såhär, nu har vi så mycket seniora personer så nu finns inte det där kvar liksom, eller att det är jobbigt som...
Ja, vilken jobbig instig när du kommer in sig här om två år att det fortfarande finns kvar.
De är bara bättre på linda in det.
Ja, det är så.
Så kan det vara, för jag var lyckligt omedvetande.
Nu har vi inga problem med att någon inte säger emot aaah.
Det jag ville komma till var en...
Eftersom du ändå har liksom papparrollen här i företaget tänker jag, har du någon gång bara samlat alla lastbilar på en stor parkeringsplats, åkt upp längst upp till ett torn och bara tittat utöver alla lastbilar och sagt, jag vill bara att ni tutar nu i fas här så att du får känna en sån här, ja fan vad mäktigt.
Kolla på allt detta.
Nej, du har inga såna...
Jag går inte igång på sånt.
Ja, vilket flöseri.
Ingenting och jag är faktiskt inte ens intresserad av lastbilar på det sättet.
Det var väldigt chockerande för mig när jag kom in i det här.
Det finns folk som verkligen älskar lastbilar.
Det var verkligen...
Alltså jag fattade liksom inte grejen.
Nej, jag köper det faktiskt.
Så jävla spännande är de kanske inte.
Men vad är det du går igång på då?
Vad är det som gör att nu tio år senare tycker du fortfarande detta är jävligt ball?
Nej, men göra någonting av ingenting, att utveckla.
Det som jag sa väldigt tidigt i början när folk frågade varför jag gör det.
Jag tror det är två saker.
Det ena är att göra en bra produkttjänst som vi är stolta över.
Det skulle kunna vara vad som helst.
Jag hade inte behövt vara här.
Fan Ali, vad du är korrekt i det här.
När du vaknar upp på morgonen och du ska så här, den här dagen ska bli fucking episk.
Fan vad kul detta ska vara.
Vilken arbetsuppgift är det då?
Jag älskar utveckling eller att komma på nya saker.
Gärna tillsammans med kollegor när vi gör något bra eller har en riktigt bra kundnöster.
Alltså sånt.
När det kickar.
Det är verkligen.
Det finns ju jäkligt mycket komplexa problem i logistik.
Det är svårt, det låter enkelt, men kortare är letiderna, ändra processerna, förbättras allt i det här.
Medicin måste ju vara en sådan.
Jag tänker när ni gick in i läkemedel måste det vara.
Helt plötsligt är det så att den här lilla paketen, det är ganska svårt att prissätta typ fyra gånger tre centimeter på ett prisvärt sätt samtidigt som man ska kunna få på leveranser, det måste ju vara knepigt.
Jättesvårt, så jag går verkligen igång på sådana problem.
Eller jag tycker att det är väldigt roligt.
Ni gick in i Norge och Danmark måste ju vara den mest underbara marknaden som finns för att allting ligger inom en kvart typ, så man behöver bara en halv hubb.
Men visst, du har pratat om andra marknader innan också, typ England vet jag att du har pratat om en gång.
Ja, precis.
Vad hände med den?
Allt kan inte vara guld och gröna skogar, ge mig ångesten.
Nej men verkligen.
Vi tog in ganska mycket riskkapital 2021, 150 miljoner, allting är ju relativt, men för oss var det mycket.
För mig är det mycket.
Ja men det är mycket för de flesta händerna.
Och det gick så jäkla bra.
Det var liksom det här hockeyklubban som alla ritade upp, det kunde vi se bakom oss.
Det var alltid så bra.
Vi hade äppnat upp i Norge, Dam, och det gick bra.
Och så tänkte jag att det är fan Tyskland och England, vi ska på de här stora marknaderna.
Så vi började resa jäkligt mycket till England och Manchester, bara träffa kunder och förstå hur ser ut marknaden där.
Det kändes jävligt bra, Tyskland likadant.
Så vi bestämde oss att vi tar England som nästa.
Och vi hade sjukt bra prospects och byggde upp en pipeline och så vidare.
Vi var också i en rekryteringsprocess så jag hittade en sjukt duktig vd för England också.
Som jag träffade jättemånga gånger och vi bådde bondade och han var villig att ta en sån risk, att gå in i ett sånt här startup i England.
Men vi visste också att gå in i England och Tyskland kräver ganska mycket mer kapital i stora länder.
Den typen av kunder vill att vi ska vara nationella ganska snabbt, annars är de inte intresserade.
Samtidigt började kriget i Ukraina, inflationen började sticka iväg.
Jag tror att i Sverige kom den lite senare, men i England drog den iväg ganska tidigt.
England fick jäkla mycket problem med sin ekonomi rätt tidigt då.
Finansmarknaden gick ner och så insåg vi att det går inte att resa pengar nu.
Det är en asdålig marknad.
Vi har ju aldrig gått så jättemycket i förlust och vi hade ganska mycket pengar i kassan.
Då är det så här, ska vi försätta oss i en jäkligt jobbig skuldläge och bli beroende av riskkapital eller ska vi backa?
Så det var väldigt tufft beslut.
Men vi bestände oss för att vi drar oss ur.
Så vi hade registrerat dotterbolag i England och så där.
Men tack och lov så vi var två minuter från signingen med vd där.
Och vi hade inte dragit igång någon drift så det var ganska billigt att lägga ner alltihopa.
Men det var verkligen en på håret.
Hade vi startat igång och kapitalmarknaden var jävligt sur.
Det hade kunnat bli mycket mycket sämre än vad det blev.
Ja det hade kunnat gå många tiotals miljoner bara på ett snabbt anslut.
Ja verkligen verkligen.
Och det som var skönt, det var ju såklart jobbigt, men det efterhand tycker jag har varit jävligt skönt.
Det var att vi har fått ro och tid att bygga.
Vi brukar kalla det för bolagets foundation-fas 2023-2020.
Vi har byggt fundament för långsiktig tillväxt och lönsamhet.
Vem är det som kommer på alla de här termerna?
Det är nog jag som är.
Success tower.
Jag vet, jag blir retad av sådana saker.
Jag har tänkt på den här plattformen som ni har byggt.
Är den din skapelse eller har du tagit in andra människor?
Nej, alltså vi har...
Jag fattar att man inte gör själv men...
Nej, alltså vet ni vad det är, den gerin bakom det är en kille som heter Andreas Bicklund som är CTO här.
Det är han som gjorde allt från scratch.
Och sen har han leda hela det utvecklingsstimt idag.
Och ni säljer den plattformen till andra fraktbolag?
Ja, precis.
Vi säljer inte så mycket till andra fraktbolag, men vi säljer den till kunder som behöver sköta sin logistik själv av en eller annan anledning.
Till exempel bolag som har massa servicebilar eller bolag som har...
Det finns ju massa olika tillämpningar där som behöver frakta farligt gods och så vidare.
Hur stor är det benet?
Är det bara en bonus för att hålla utvecklarnas lön typ igång?
Eller är det en stor del?
Nej, men än så länge är det en liten del.
Jag tror att vi omsätter 30 miljoner på SaaS-affären.
Även om det är en liten del så är 30 miljoner inte så liten för ett sånt.
Det skulle kunna vara ett litet bolag som sköter sig.
Är det som Amazon Services, de tjänar as mycket på själva Amazon, men de tjänar as mycket på sina services?
Så är det och det är väl det som har varit lite grann förebilden och tanken också.
Sen har vi inte helt ärligt satsat jättemycket på försäljning av plattformen.
Jag tror att kommande åren kan Lenn fosas upp mycket mer.
Jag hoppas att det har mycket mer potential.
Jag bara gillar det som ett ultra SC-rockar, men man sitter i en tung investerad dialog och de bara vi kollar på bolaget, det ser bra ut, vi ska nog gå in.
Och så bara drar man fram den här.
By the way, vi har en liten SAS-tjänst här som har en rätt god vinstmarginal.
Du vet att den ligger med också.
Du tänkte inte på den eller?
Kolla.
Nej men den är ju jätteskyld.
Ni har dragit igång någonting som heter Gordon Circular.
Ja.
Vill du berätta vad det är?
Jag har lite svårt att läsa mig till vad det är.
Nej men det är en...
Du vet när vi faktiskt har sjukt mycket mat hem till konsumenter och det är två riktigt dåliga saker med det.
Det ena är att...
Fan du säljer in detta nu.
Kan vi inte bara klippa det?
Kan vi inte bara skita i det här?
Vi stänger avsnittet.
Men det ena är att kunden får så jäkla mycket papperskastar eller kartonger om man har beställt HelloFresh eller Linas matkastar eller handlar på Coop online.
Du får så mycket pappersavfall som man måste hantera.
Antingen går till återvinningen hela tiden och så vidare och det får vi klagomål på att kunden inte gillar det.
Det andra är ju att det är sjukt mycket avfall.
Det är liksom, du packar saker som redan är för att packa det en gång till i någon papp som ska wastas.
Och hela pappersförbrukningen går ju bara upp varje år.
Idén kom faktiskt, om jag ska vara helt ärlig, kom från ett dansk bolag som försökte göra det här men de gjorde det så jävligt dåligt.
De fattade ingenting om logistik.
Så de utvecklade någon produkt för att cirkulera mat.
Men den var så sjukt dålig.
Det triggade igång att fan, här kan vi göra, vi är den bäst lämpade för att göra en cirkulär förpackningslösning så att man kan ta bort all pappersavfall.
Så väldigt, väldigt konkret då.
Det går en cirkulär i ett system där kunderna, alltså våra kunder, säg Couponline eller Linas Matgasse, de får enheter för att förpacka sin mat i.
De här enheterna består av två komponenter, ena är en plastback och den andra en tygpåse som de lägger maten i.
Den här tygpåsen är utvecklats för att kunna cirkuleras 50 gånger.
Efter varje loop så går den till en tvätteri och tvättas för att ta bort alla allergier och så tillbaka till produktionen.
Så cirklar man det.
Konsumenten får bara den här tygkassen som man går ner och stoppar i en låda.
Den tar ingen plats.
För det är också jätteviktigt.
Man vill inte ha några plastbackar hemma.
Det tar massa plats.
Och det som vi har det är techplatsformen för att kunna, vi vet exakt hur många sådana kassar varje kund har i sitt hem.
Och vi kan påminna om nästa hämtning.
Och det vi har lärt oss väldigt mycket nu när vi har, jag vet inte, vi ligger på 20-30 000 lopar än så länge med Gordon Circular.
Och det ökar lojaliteten sjukt mycket.
Kundernas snittköp ökar de som använder Circular.
Och vi sänker liksom, ja men vi sänker ju e-handlarnas kundrekruteringskostnad.
Men hur lämnar de tillbaka?
Gör de det vid nästa köp då?
Hänger det ut?
Nu vid nästa köp, hänger det ut precis.
Och de får information om det liksom, att förbereda sig att vi kan hämta dem.
Men det är något de signar upp för, eller är det?
Det är lite, lite, det är upp till e-handlaren.
Antingen kan de göra den till.
Jag tänkte säga förblida annars att kunden får betala för att de inte har lämnat tillbaka den här produkten då.
Precis, det här var en huvudfråga när vi startade.
Behöver vi ha pant, hur ska vi göra liksom?
Ska vi köra biblioteksmodellen som lämnar du tillbaka boken så kostar det.
Men vi är nästan, alltså inget svinn, det är nästan allt kommit tillbaka.
Alltså vi är helt sjuka, vilken returnrate vi har.
Så vi har struntat i det.
Men det är upp till vår e-handlande att bestämma om det ska vara obligatoriskt eller om det ska vara optional med circular.
Fan, det är en smart idé.
Framförallt för att det är ett jävla gött försäljningsargument mot e-handlaren.
För det blir verkligen en påminnelse.
Vi körde ju mat typ tre gånger hemma eller något sånt där och jag hatade de här stora jävla lådorna som man var tvungen att gå och slänga.
Man fick typ sparkas under de jävla kartongerna.
Jag vet.
Och sen gick man och slängde.
Och framförallt så var det ju att man skete i det sen för man glömde att du vet, jag orkar inte mäcka med det här.
Men hade jag haft en sån där grej som stod och påminde mig så kanske jag hade haft 10% större chans att köpa det som ett säljargument.
Det är en jävla bra...
Vem kom på den här idén?
Det var jag som var lite drivande i det.
Så har vi en kollega som heter Charlotte som utvecklat konceptet ihop väldigt mycket i början och så har vi haft en massa andra folk som har tagit över.
Jag fattar att det är flera människor.
Någon gång måste man bara ha sagt tanken, det är bara jävligt bra tank.
Så upptäcker man att det finns fler fördelar med detta.
För från början tänker man på det som någon sorts miljöprodukt, men det är ingen e-handlare som i slutändan kommer köpa produkten för det.
De kommer gilla det och de kommer sälja in det, men de kommer inte köpa det på grund av det.
Men däremot om det ökar lojaliteten med nänna procent så är det ju en fucking episk lösning.
Nej men verkligen, verkligen.
Som sista sådär, är detta din stora forever baby eller skulle du kunna lämna det?
Nu har du hållit på i tio år, hur tänker du på framtiden efter den där miljarden?
Ja, nej men jag har aldrig sett det som en forever baby, så det är farligt tror jag att ha den typen av attachment också.
För om du inte är rätt person för att driva det då kan du ju dra ner alltihopa liksom.
Det är viktigt att våga lämna över när det är dags.
Och den tiden kommer ju säkert.
Men skitsårsfråga, jag vet inte.
Jag tycker det är svårt att se mer än tre till fem år bort.
Forever låter lite långt i gröna.
Hade du haft en till företagsresa i dig?
Detta är ändå en stark skalning eller hade du bara nej då kommer jag nog konsulta lite, har det gött?
Det var innan jag satt i Gårdon.
Nej, efter du, säg att du hade lämnat Gårdon nu.
Hade du orkat driva upp en till sån här resa då?
Precis, jag tänker att jag inte kommer göra det.
Men jag tror att det vet man inte.
Jag har svårt att sitta och inte göra någonting hemma.
Men jag kanske ska göra lite andra saker, jag vet inte.
Exakt, skitbra, bra, konkret.
Jättebra, stort tack för att du var med i podden.
Fan vilket gött avsnitt och all lycka till här framöver.
Tack, jättekul att prata med mig.
Har du nån gång samlat alla lastbilar på en stor parkeringsplats och åkt upp längst upp till ett torn och bara tittat ut över alla lastbilar och sagt jag vill bara att ni tutar nu i fas här så du får känna en sådan här...